الرؤية هنا حلم
نحن في صحراء
الأحلام ونسميها صحراء الأحلام
لأن أجدادنا ووالدنا المؤسس
حلموا
بالصحراء وأنت تشاهد الصحاري والصور
وأحياناً الأفلام الوثائقية وتشعر وكأنك
حياتهم عاشوها في الصحراء
وازدهروا في الصحراء وحلموا في
الصحراء هل تسمع صوته
هذا هو الصوت الأول الذي
نلعبه في اللحظة
التي تبدأ فيها رحلتك في
الجناح أردنا أن يكون هذا هو
الصوت الأول الذي  يستمع الناس إلى أنه
حلمنا الأول ، إنه الأب
المؤسس للمنفى
بالنسبة لنا ، أنت تعلم أنه
الأب هو والد حلمنا منذ أكثر
من 50 عامًا ، أخذ الشيخ زايد
جناح أبو ظبي إلى معرض أوساكا ، وذلك
قبل توحيد البلاد
اليوم  بلاده تستضيف
العالم ، يتم تكريم الإرث وتكريمه من
خلال شعب الإمارات
سواء كانوا من الإمارات
أو في الإمارات العربية المتحدة منذ يوم ولادته
هو من خلال عيون الناس  من خلال
أفعالهم من
خلال ما نراه والمعالم التي
نحققها كل يوم
عندما تتتبعها ، يمكنك تتبعها
إلى والدنا المؤسس
هذه الفكرة عن الشيخ زايد باعتباره
حالمًا هي فكرة مشتركة تجري
في الجناح وفي التصميم
أرادت نورا أن
يفهم الزائرون حقًا إرث زياد باعتباره صاحب
الرؤية المسؤول عن توحيد
البلاد منذ خمسة عقود ،
وهنا بيكي
أم هو النوع الأول من عنصر
إظهار أول شيخ حالمنا الشيخ زايد
مع
الإشارة إلى الآباء المؤسسين ورسم صور أخرى  على
الرمال لذلك نحن محاطون بها هنا
نزرع ومن هنا هذا
عندما دعا العالم لبناء
الدولة معه
فهذه هي قصة الوحدة
ترفع الأصوات ترفع الأنوار
يتجمع الناس أكثر في هذا.  ضع دائرة
لتظهر لضيوفنا
أن الوحدة قوية ، إنها بصوت عالٍ
، وأم يقولها يقولها
بكلماته الخاصة حيث يمثل
بالنسبة
له طريق القوة من
خلال juxtapos  من خلال انتقال ماضي الإمارات
عبر حاضرها والنظر إلى
المستقبل ، يكرّم الجناح أيضًا
تكريمًا خاصًا للأبطال المجهولين الذين
يشكلون نسيج الإمارات الذين صنعوه
، والفكرة هي أن هذا الجناح
يعكس قصص 200
جنسية  يسمى منزل الإمارات العربية
المتحدة وبالنسبة لنورا امرأة إماراتية
نشأت هنا بعد ولادة الأمة ، فإن
التنوع هو حجر الزاوية في قصة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
قصتنا تتجاوز
ناطحات السحاب ، إنها هذه
هي أولئك الأشخاص الذين
يعيشون الحلم معنا و  هناك قصة أه
بيكي عن زايد عندما كان في
الصحراء
أه كان يقف في الصحراء
ويقول هناك مستشفى هناك
مصنع وأصدقائه ماتوا إنها
صحراء
هذه صحراء الزيات رأى الصحراء
لكنه رأى  المستقبل ،
لذلك في هذه التجربة الغامرة
، كلما زاد عدد الأشخاص الذين يقفون أمام
الصحراء ، فهذا يعكس المستقبل
[موسيقى]